at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
[Music]
books i've loved on the tim ferriss show
is exclusively brought to you by
audible there couldn't be a better
sponsor for this series my dear
listeners and readers
i have used audible for so many years as
long as i can remember i love it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet i listen when
i'm taking walks
i listen while i'm cooking i listen
whenever i can
and if you're looking for a place to
start i can recommend three of my
favorites
the first is the tao of seneca
by seneca if you want to hear my
favorite letters of all time
touches on stoic philosophy calmness
under duress
etc the next is the graveyard book by
neil
gaiman g-a-i-m-a-n one of my favorites
even if you're a non-fiction
purist this is the fiction book that you
need to listen to
neil also has perhaps the most calming
voice of all time
and third greg mcewen's essentialism
subtitled the disciplined pursuit of
less this is one of my favorite books of
the past few years combines
very well with the 80 20 principle but
more on audible
every month audible members get one
credit for any audio book on the site
plus a choice of multiple audible
originals from a rotating selection they
also get access to daily news digests
from the likes of the new york times
wall street journal and the washington
post
as well as guided meditation programs
and here are some other amazing audible
features and i use a bunch of these you
can download titles and listen offline
anytime
anywhere i use this feature
even when i could get access i'll put my
phone on say airplane mode
because i don't want to get bothered
with notifications and i'm taking a walk
to clear my head
and you can listen to your titles
offline in a case like that or on a
plane or whatever obviously i'm not
flying much these days
the app is free and can be installed on
all smartphones and tablets you can
listen across devices without losing
your spot
and whispersync is another feature i use
quite a lot i love reading my kindle in
bed for instance
then picking up at the same exact spot
where i left off when i go walking and
listening the next day
kindle and audio versions can be synced
up automatically it's just amazing
and if you can't decide what to listen
to don't sweat it you don't have to rush
you can keep your credits for up to a
year and use them
for instance to binge on a whole series
if you like audible offers just about
everything podcasts
guided wellness programs theatrical
performances a-list comedy and audible
originals you won't find
anywhere else and right now audible is
offering you guys
that's tim ferriss show listeners a free
audio book with a
30-day trial membership and
again my list if you want to check them
out the tao of seneca
the graveyard book essentialism those
are just three there's so many good ones
out there
just go to audible.com tim
and browse the unmatched selection of
audio programs
then download your free title and start
listening it's that easy let's check it
out go to audible.com
tim or text tim tim to
500 500 to get started today check it
out
audible.com tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is usually my job to sit down
with world-class performers of all
different types
startup founders investors chess
champions olympic athletes you name it
to tease out the habits that you can
apply in your own lives
this episode however is an experiment
and part of a short form series that i'm
doing
simply called books i've loved i've
invited some amazing past
guests close friends and new faces to
share their favorite books
describe their favorite books the books
that have influenced them changed them
transform them for the better and i hope
you pick up one or two
new mentors in the form of books from
this new series and apply the lessons in
your own life
i had a lot of fun putting this together
inviting these people to participate
and have learned so so much myself i
hope that is also the case for you
please enjoy
timbo this
is cal fussman the host of big questions
podcast
i say that with great pride and thanks
because if it weren't for you
i wouldn't have my podcast not only did
you have me as a guest on yours
twice but then you kept on nudging me to
start my own
and then you help me set it up
and it's transformed my life so much
gratitude brother
i know you like to ask this question
about books and the beauty of it
is that you can get a different response
from someone in 2019
than when you asked him in 2016 because
they might have read 100 or 150 new
books during that time
i do have to confess a weakness here i
generally don't stop and wonder hmm
what book should i read next nearly all
of my reading revolves around who i'm
going to interview next
a lot of the people i've interviewed for
big questions or esquire magazine over
the last two decades
have written books so that's the bulk of
my reading
and this leads to my recommendation for
your listeners
actually a couple of recommendations i'm
going to make here
i know you'll get behind these
recommendations because these books
were written by somebody i first heard
on your podcast the tidying up
guru marie kondo
i got a chance to interview marie on
stage at a recent event for rocketing
marie is that company's ambassador of
joy
and i've got to say i think she's one of
the most unique
people on the planet certainly a master
at what she does in fact
i walked away from the experience
thinking she's a genius
i'll tell you why in a second but first
let me mention the book she's written
first is called the life-changing magic
of tidying up and subtitled the japanese
art of decluttering
and organizing she might have had an
editor declutter that title a bit but
hey
it became a new york times bestseller
and it sold 9 million copies
the second book is called spark joy
an illustrated master class on the art
of organizing
and tidying up when we were up on stage
i wanted to give the audience a taste of
marie's writing
so i read from a section about
storing socks it's on page 80 of her
first book
the life-changing magic of tidying up
and i've got to say
i've read shakespeare dostoyevsky
gabriel garcia marquez mark twain
this section written by marie is one of
the most
original thoughts i've encountered
i never thought i'd see socks brought to
life on a printed page
but listen to how marie looks at them
so i'm going to page 80. a little title
here says storing socks
treat your socks and stockings with
respect and here goes
have you ever had the experience where
you thought what you were doing was a
good thing
but later learned that it had hurt
someone
at the time you were totally unconcerned
oblivious to the other person's feelings
this is somewhat similar to the way many
of us
treat our socks i visited the home of a
client in her fifties
as always we started with her clothes we
moved through her wardrobe at a smooth
pace
finished the underwear and were ready to
start
organizing her socks
but when she pulled open her sock drawer
i could not suppress a gasp
it was full of potato-like lumps that
rolled about
she had folded back the tops to form
balls
and tied her stockings tightly in the
middle
i was speechless dressed in a crisp
white apron my client smiled at me and
said
it's easy to pick out what i need this
way and it's quite
simple to put them away as well don't
you think
although i frequently run into this
attitude during my lessons
it never fails to astonish me
let me state here and now
never ever tie up your stockings
never ever ball up your
socks i pointed to the balled up socks
look at them carefully this should be a
time for them to rest
do you really think they can get any
rest like that
that's right the socks and stockings
stored in your drawer
are essentially on holiday they take a
brutal beating in their daily work
trap between your foot and your shoe
enduring pressure and friction to
protect your precious feet
the time they spend in your drawer is
their
only chance to rest but if they are
folded over
balled up or tied they are always in a
state of tension
their fabric stretched in their elastic
pulled they roll about and bump into
each other every time the drawers open
and closed any socks and stockings
unfortunate enough
to get pushed to the back of the drawer
are often forgotten for so long
that their elastic stretches beyond
recovery
when the owner finally discovers them
and puts them on
it will be too late and they will be
relegated to the garbage
what treatment could be worse than
this well tim all i can say
is i've never balled up a pair of socks
since
and marie showed me how to fold a pair
of socks on stage
anybody who wants to know how to fold a
pair of socks
can turn to page 99 of her second book
spark joy there is a full page of
illustrations
devoted to sock management
these two books and my talk with marie
on stage have
really changed the way i think they've
liberated me to see the things that i
own
in a different way if they are not
completely useful
or they don't spark joy marie recommends
offering thanks to them and then it's
sayonara when she goes into somebody's
home to tidy up
she has a system she starts with clothes
first then papers and books
then sentimental items she's found it
easiest to make decisions on clothes
sentimental items come last because
they're the hardest to part with
now i got to admit tim i needed marie
very badly
i've had a lot of experiences in my life
and quite
often i've kept physical objects from
these experiences
as mementos i'm beginning to worry
that i might need five houses to store
them all
i needed a way to pare down the mother
lode
so what i did was bring a few
sentimental items on stage with me to
see if marie could tell me
if i should keep them or get rid of them
i hope what transpired
will compel people to buy those two
bucks
the first item was very unique never
seen another like it
it's a small garbage can made out of
wine corks
the corks are glued together in a circle
and at the bottom the build the bin
is held up by a base of magnum
champagne corks i laughed the first time
i saw it
it was in the office of the best
sommelier in america at the time
andrea emmer now she's andrea emma
robinson
angie's office was at windows on the
world at the top of the world trade
center this was back in 2000
and i didn't know much about wine back
then and andrea
was helping to teach me how to be a
sommelier
for a story i was writing for esquire
magazine
in fact for one night in 2001
i did become the sommelier at windows on
the world
just before the hijacked planes came in
and took down the towers on 911
which is one of the reasons that this
garbage can is still with me
see what happened is that andrea was
leaving for a more advanced position in
cleaning out her office
she didn't know what to do with this
garbage can made of wine corks
i think somebody had gifted it to her
and probably they didn't know what to do
with it either
i couldn't imagine what anybody would do
with a garbage can made of wine corks
i even remember making fun of it so as
andrea cleaned out her office
she passed it on to a public relations
person
who was standing next to me when i made
fun of it about a year later
this public relations person left her
job for a better position
and remembered me making fun of the wine
cork
garbage can so as a sort of gag
she passed it on to me i didn't know
what to do with it
so i put it in my basement where i
stored my wine
and i did find a use for it i began to
toss
inside this garbage can the quirks of
the really good bottles that i
enjoyed that way i could save the corks
and the memories inside these corks
i went on to do my night as sommelier at
windows on the world
it's one of the best nights of my life
and very soon
afterward the towers were taken down
on 911. now this full story takes a
while to tell
and if anybody wants to read it they can
google cocktails before the collapse on
esquire.com
bottom line here is i was so shaken by
the entire experience
took me 10 years to write that story
anyway this garbage can made of wine
quarks was the
only physical thing
left that i had from windows on the
world
i couldn't get rid of it i moved across
the country
and over the years some of the champagne
cork legs began to fall off
but i just couldn't bear to throw out
this
garbage can into a garbage can
now having read marie's books
i knew her mo if it sparks joy
yeah keep it if it makes your insides go
yeah keep it but this garbage can made
of wine corks contained
many layers of emotions it was filled
with the corks of
some of the great tastes of my life and
some incredibly happy moments that came
with them
but it was also filled with a profound
sadness
that to this day has no depths
i had no idea how marie would react to
all this when i told her the story there
was a gasp from the audience
a hush and then a prolonged silence
nobody knew how marie would respond
she took the garbage can of cork
in her hands and i'm telling you tim it
was almost like
watching a shaman reach into the
spiritual
being of this garbage can of wine corks
she closed her eyes as if she were using
all of her
powers to pull out the essence
of my experience and then
she turned to me and said
keep it tim i'm telling you
when she handed it back to me i wanted
to
hug it like a baby i never thought i'd
ever love a garbage can like a child
which goes to prove this is not about
things
this is about spirit
so i was very excited to show her the
second item
it was a photo of me boxing with julio
cesar chavez when he was a junior
welterweight champion of the world
at the time he had 87 wins no losses i
think it was for 84 knockouts or so
and in this photo i'm landing a left
hook on his
jaw photos framed about two feet wide by
18 inches tall
captures one of the best moments of my
life
in fact it's a wonder i still have my
life after i got in the ring with him
thankfully julio had a sense of humor
about the session
we did it for a magazine story i i
definitely told that story on your
podcast so people can hear it there
here's the thing anybody sitting in the
audience in front of marie and i
had to know how i felt about this photo
kaching
ah but there was a catch
does it bring you joy marie asked
oh yes i said so much joy that you know
what i did
i had the same photo blown up to the
size
of an entire wall from my office
so that every day i go to write
i can see myself in the ring with one of
the greatest fighters who ever lived
and not only that but actually landing a
punch
it's a daily reminder to me that
whatever i can dream
i can do so marie i tell her
here's the problem i have this same
photo
filling up an entire wall in my office
what should i do with this smaller one
no
an outside observer looking at it now
might see it as pretty large
marie took the photo in her lap and
slowly circled the hand over it i'm
telling you tim
it was like she was burrowing into the
depths
of the six months i trained to get into
the ring with julio
every punch i took in training every
sit-up
every time a medicine ball got slammed
into my gut
she turned to me
keep it she said
now i was beginning to get a little
nervous tim because if she was as
attached to my sentimental items as i
was
if she was that attached to those items
i was in big trouble
i'm telling you tim i just moved
and my wife looked at the boxes filled
with mementos that were filling up the
new place
and she just flat out asked me
what is this a home
or the kal fussman museum well
i definitely need to get rid of some
stuff
so i pulled out my next item for marie
i knew this would go directly to her
heart
it was a beautiful fan from her homeland
japan her face slit up when she saw it
there were a lot of japanese people in
the audience rakitan is a japanese
electronic
commerce company founded by mickey
mikitani
the audience wanted to know the story
the handle on this fan
gave way to an oval that looked like
parchment
and on this parchment were illustrations
of a festival
in kishiwara it's called dangeri
every october half a million people
fill the streets to watch this festival
it's a
wild parade of wooden floats
the size of old-fashioned stage coaches
that are ornately carved and decorated
they have to have been built hundreds of
years ago and there are
long ropes in front of each coach i mean
really long ropes long enough to fit
30 40 50 young guys dressed in black
who line up to pull these floats through
the streets at blistering speeds
while other guys are dancing on top of
the floats and waving these fans
then everyone eats crab and drinks beer
well i always wanted to go to kishiwara
and run with one of these teams i was
told about this festival
by a japanese woman back in 1994
but my wife had just gotten pregnant and
it was not the time for me to run off to
this festival
so this japanese woman gave me this fan
as a way of saying
i hope one day you will get to the don
jitti
until you do have this
as a memento well it's been 25 years
i never got to run in the danger but i
still
have the fan does it spark joy marie
asked
oh yes makes me very happy she took it
in her hands
and lifted out the spirit
and she turned to me give it as a gift
to someone in the audience she said
and make plans to go to the festival
the crowd applauded and many people in
the audience approached me afterward and
asked for the fan
i gave it to the first person who came
up to me a man who promised
that he would never give it away now
a friendship between that man and i may
come out of that exchange but something
else occurred to me
something i didn't mention to marie that
told me
how truly great her powers are
you see tim when i first brought this
fan home
i noticed that my wife was not a big fan
of that fan
my wife's brazilian she was pregnant
and hormonal and now that i look back
upon it
she certainly didn't like the fact that
i was treasuring a gift
i'd received from another woman i'm sure
my wife was
jealous of that fan from kishiwada
so marie had removed the jealousy from
my home
put me in the position to make a new
friend and then
nudged me to run in that festival
where those experiences might take me
to even greater places
and i will go to that festival and who
knows where it will take me
now i realize that not everyone is going
to be
able to trot their clothes and
sentimental items out for marie condo
and have her tidy up her their lives but
you see
that's why i'm recommending her books to
your listeners
i believe they will turn your listeners
homes
into sacred space
cheers brother hey guys this is tim
again just a few more things before you
take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little more soul
of fun before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four-hour
workweek.com that's four-hour
workweek.com all spelled out and just
drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy